hello I'm calling with film independent
of welcome to coffee talks I'm thrilled
to bring you this bonus episode this
week featuring two the most acclaimed
filmmakers working in cinema today first
up is Kelly Riker
she's the five-time Spirit Award
nominated director she's been nominated
the best first feature for river of
grass John Cassavetes award for all joy
and for Best Director for certain women
she's also the winner of this year's
Bonnie awarded Spirit Awards her other
credits include Meeks cut off Wendy and
Lucy and this year's first cow which was
one of the last films to be released in
theaters before the lockdown first cow
will be released on all digital
platforms on July 10th and fingers
crossed we'll see a second theatrical
run later in the year and joining Kelly
were very thrilled to have all the way
from Athens Greece yoga's LAN Tomas his
breakout hit dogtooth should be on
everyone's quarantine playlist I think
that of course was Oscar nominated for
Best Foreign Language Film
his other credits include caneta oops
the lobster the killing of a sacred deer
and the favorite which was nominated for
Best International Film and also
received 10 Oscar nominations as well
winning one for Olivia Kamen for Best
Actress and now due to the time zones
Kenny being here and your ghosts being
in Greece and their availability this is
a coffee talk we actually recorded
earlier so I'll let Kelly and us take it
away we were in quarantine here but you
know everyone's on the street now
marching at night yeah and so we're
pretty close together everyone has a
mask though but yeah probably gonna be
some fall back from that probably but I
mean how do you weigh the pros and the
cons of these guys no yeah for sure
the numbers have been kind of low here
important so sweet
what's that grease did really well
[Music]
containing it and so you know we opened
up since Monday it's amaze the things
that you appreciate once the quarantine
is done you know I don't see how we'll
be done we have no organization every
state is different
ya know central it's madness here yeah
so it's hard I haven't been watching
films or thinking about films at all
really it's hard isn't it yes I watched
your film should we say all these things
now I think they'll edit this thing no
can I talk about you yeah I mean yeah it
feels weird to ya talk about film but we
should I guess I don't know that's what
were meant to do but I did write that we
we will played it cool and we said like
we don't need a moderator and I think
we'll do it ourselves and yeah I wasn't
expecting um when we made those
decisions the world blew up like a
second time since then here anyway
yeah things have just been so yeah it's
hard to you know think about anything
else or sleep or anything because it's
just so fucked up there's been something
positive I've been watching some videos
with some you know some positive you
know sheriff's and people and like
trying to deescalate things and you know
joining people and you know at least
there's some some of that
I mean what we had on the ocean yeah we
we had all these months of watching our
medical workers you know reusing their
materials every night in the hospital
like they have no gear at all
and now you see these cops and they are
loaded with gear they have every kind of
accoutrement they're ready like
certainly no you see where all the money
is going you know and certainly not -
yeah so but it's a time of great
contradictions I mean you have to stay
away from each other but in order to
nice to be with people last night though
I have to say it was very beautiful we
marched over a bridge and it was it felt
really good to be with people and then I
mean when you get to the other side of
the river and downtown it gets then
there's definitely some hooligans that
show up just like uh and you know but
made my exit before then but I don't
know it felt good to be with people but
I yeah I wonder what it's probably not I
don't know everyone had masks Don I just
can't tell what these masks are really
doing it's like a pizza it's like having
a t-shirt over your face but yeah so
you've been out to eat so far yeah
you've been out marching and I went to a
restaurant do they just let a little few
people in it's it's mostly outside so
the restaurants that are that have
tables outside you can you can go and if
you know they keep their distances and
all that so it's been good yeah I'm
appreciating a meal and you're a pretty
appreciating protest
meaning where we were a year ago it's
insane
yeah I joined there's no yeah there's no
Cannes Film Festival
there's no yeah we could never imagine
those kind of things like we got in
there right under the radar yeah yeah is
your film coming out though it's the
kind it came out for uh like we came out
on Friday and March and I think the
theaters closed like after the yeah
first weekend or something I don't know
we played for one minute and then so now
it's just gonna go on video on demand on
Apple I think because yeah so you know
you're gross I would have made a lot of
different decisions if I knew it wasn't
gonna play the theatres I wouldn't hurt
shot in four three and I wouldn't have
spent like nine days doing the color
time meeting for a theatrical release
and then uh eight hours doing it before
but I mean isn't that always a bit of a
problem like yeah because people you
know only a percentage of people who'll
ever watch your film you know on in this
cinema so you kind of have to always
take in consideration that there's gonna
people that are gonna watch it on a big
screen on their laptop on a big TV at
home on an iPhone and on an iPad so it's
cuz it does cross my mind you know every
time that I you know try to finish a
film and and it's just like you can't
really you know do you know justice to
all of these different you know way it's
used to be don't you think like it's
less separate than it used to be
but even closer to something but you
would have to go around and set
everyone's television so I was trying to
moving motion things I was a 24 did do a
little like preamp with crisp lava would
tell people how to set their televisions
so but switch off fluid motion that
lacks everything looks like a soap opera
yeah or like a basketball game you know
callers and contrast and all these
things what did you watch on what's your
film on a really big no-no I have a
really big TV but obviously it was a you
know it's a link so it's the compressed
file and but it was still I mean it's
great like I know that you you know
you're gutted when you know how people
watch your films but went to film you
know the essence of the film you know
doesn't get lost no matter how you watch
it I know it's painful for us that we've
made that when we know you know how
different the experience would have been
but you know like like I said like I
told you and I'm I guess I won't say too
many of these kind of things but like I
was you know so moved watching your film
and still I could see you know pixels
and whatever and compression and but I
mean I I got over it like you know two
minutes in I know I was drawn in and I
never you know thought about these
things again and I was just you know
yeah completely drawn in and ya know I
was really moved
it's because I know I know you and
but it's it doesn't happen you know very
often for me to what you know filming
and I'm not saying I'm I don't mean like
being moved as some of the story you
know moved me it's just like the the the
the the act of actually watching a real
film and how you know that just you know
short by short and you know second by
second that there's something which is
not rational that you know steers
something in inside you and you're you
know you you realize that you're
watching something you know that that is
important to you for whatever reason
it's and it's not rational so you know
the technical stuff you know of course
we were very nice
yeah his pixels were beautiful telling
ya I do it the intention behind the
pixels so what we do there are you
writing yes it's been hard it's been
really hard I mean it's because I've for
the first time I've started quite a few
projects like over the years and then I
made two films back-to-back and now they
kind of piled up and I was I had this
time now you know in a lockdown where I
went like oh this is gonna be you know
really useful time to figure everything
out and work on all of these different
projects and but I really I find it
really difficult to focus like even when
you were just you know locked inside a
house and especially if it's a one-room
apartment like there's I don't know what
it is but it's like you also have to do
like every little thing all the chores
that you have to do that in a house to
tidy everything to cook to clean to eat
- and it just becomes this like you you
you you know you think that you don't
have enough time to do anything else
and then it's like you have to decide
okay which where I'm which one am I
gonna focus on now and is it this one or
oh maybe I should do that other thing
that I need to do and I don't know I
find it really difficult to organize in
one place okay in the same room yeah
no but I finally I think I you know I
managed to get a system going where I'd
said like I'm gonna decide probably you
know in terms of I'll start from the
oldest project that I started to work on
and I'll go like that chronological
order so you know this week is gonna be
this project which is your project is
probably like eight nine yeah um
everything that do you I mean if you
watch a film now and everyone's
gathering you have a different sense
about it right in the movie you like oh
yeah like do you think there'll be a
every I guess you know like thinking of
the things of the big things in life
nine eleven eight would have like you
get back to some kind of new normal but
you think of the project from eight
years ago can be relevant I mean I'm
worried about the project from five
weeks you know yeah if it's relevant but
you don't want everything yeah yeah the
funny thing is that the oldest project
that I have is a film that we were
writing which is about a plague in
London which was which was inspired by
you know the Black Plague in London but
it's it's written as I can
temporary black comedy and it was so
strange to be reading this again like
amidst the whole situation and it took
like a whole new meaning and you saw
things very differently and you know all
the things that you you you thought that
were extreme that we were including you
know they turned out to be nothing
compared to what happens in reality and
then you you're so educated about the
subject matter now like you know you
know you know so much more we're now
everything in the script is is like oh
they wouldn't do that they would use
these kind of gloves and and you got
like I really need to but our intention
was always not to make something
extremely realistic and yeah based on a
very specific kind of disease or
anything like that and it's a much more
you know like an absurd absurd kind of
healing healing disease where you don't
know where it really is coming from so
it it gave us a push to go even more
towards that direction we're you know
but anyway it was funny to deal with
something like that while this is going
on but also yeah of course all the films
we saw last year at con how many of them
were zombie films it's like a
foreshadowing of are you working with
the same writing partner all the time or
different you have different projects
going with different people
no it's different I mean I I I've
written you know most of my films with a
famous that we're friends and you know
we started you know writing the Greek
films together and then some the English
language films
and then I started working with other
people too like Tony that we wrote the
favorite and now I'm writing with him
another project so it's a it's a couple
of people that I've written more than
one things and then now I'm working with
even more people Pat you pass drops back
and forth to each other yeah I mean it's
this this stuff with a famous that we
write I mean it's we start from scratch
they're all original ideas that we come
up with so it's a lot of you know
discussions and brainstorming and ideas
coming from one and the other and one
takes one's idea and you know tries to
go further with it and then when we have
a story in a structure and you know the
the scenes I mean he does most of the
writing but that's like a very
collaborative process and then with
other people for the time being most of
the of the stuff are based on on
something like even the favorite which
is I mean it's not based on a book or
anything but it's you know it's based on
a real person and and some facts in the
real story and then yeah we're adapting
novels and things so with the other
writers it's mostly having material that
we work on so I you know follow
development and help with the structure
and the ideas and the tone and all of
these things and and they do the writing
and and but how about you because you've
written most of her films with John
right yeah yeah except for to be yeah
it's been a little different each one
because you the early month came from
some short stories okay
and then I'm didn't other ones we like
you said a million coffees and talking
and chatting he lives very close by and
sometimes like him before
did you know him before or you read his
work he was Todd's friend and I met him
but then I read his first novel which
was the half life which became first cow
yeah um there's no cow in the half life
though but it's much more it's a from
what I read you the the novel from what
the film ended up being right no I
didn't read the novel or the characters
well the king Lou character is like a
fusion of two characters from the book
but otherwise the friendship is pretty
you know but it um same it's a lot of
coffee drinking and hanging out mulling
things over and thinking and then a lot
of ideas and notes and then John oice
writes the first pass which is the you
know the meet I would say and then I
start I immediately just take it all
apart and try to so I can understand it
and then just start of yeah working on
it myself just for transitions and you
know and I I add characters I guess and
like I have the foundation and and then
I add what we call the surface funk
then we borrow Manny Farber's a term and
then you know it goes back and forth and
but a lot of times we go to places you
know it's like sometimes based on a
location like is it kind of a key thing
the thing we're working on now is based
on this I mean we set it in this school
that has closed and now been sold and
every time we go visit it they're
carrying things out of it and taking
apart what's great about it so
but he's it again with John it's with
John yeah he he does the heavy lifting
as far as the writing goes for sure I
like things are like the scenes and the
scenes but like the getting from this
scene to that scene and how things
connect need to be shot like okay yeah
there's lots of room to be creative and
get inside it but it's it's I wouldn't
like to deal with the blank page and and
the characters are pretty yeah he's
really good at anyway yeah I like his
writing quite a lot obviously yeah and
was it did you always knew that you want
did you always know that you wanted to
make half life into a film when you met
him and then ended up doing the other
films first well I knew I couldn't make
the half life into a film so I after I
read the half life I wrote him and asked
him if you had any short stories they
could be shot all outside with like two
people and something I could write a dog
into and he sent me he I have his first
email to me like boy sent me old joy
which had come out in a book of
photographs with this photographer there
is Justine Kurland really great
photographer I love and she um he wrote
when I wrote him and said you know could
I make this a film I have his first you
know he's like yeah I guess whatever yet
a lot of me but you know now he gets
really into it you know any
knows all the people on the crew and
everything it gets he gets so it's nice
also just to yeah I don't know it's nice
that part of it just to I when I did a
certain women on my own it's like it's
hard just not having the yeah what it's
hard writing but was with certain women
also based on collection of stories from
two books by Miley Molloy and and how
did you decide to do that on your own
John one take a break with them not
being his surge stories yeah he was he
was gonna make he was doing stuff with
Todd Haynes at the time and so uh yeah I
so you know it's very motivated by spite
and jealousy of my two closest friends
going off to work together now no he um
in fairness he had two children in the
time we started working together and
he's trying to make a living whatever
you know and but I know we did
what's I did you end up enjoying writing
the search or was struggle and it was
really hard I couldn't find the in John
you know read drafts for me and stuff he
was great he it was just I didn't not
being able to like I made them like with
John I could show John to draft and I'd
be like this is really crap like it's
just read it see if there's anything
good in here this is like really crappy
and I'm not embarrassed to show him that
and I cuz its but I at one point was
really stuck and I didn't know Miley at
all and I sent her and I said this is a
really crap draft I'm just trying to see
if there's anything good in here like
what I feel like there's some
and um oh my god like she didn't use
just like someone taking her store it
was it was really I I got off the phone
with her I was staying at Todd's house
at the time and I remember I went and
crawled in his bed for like six hours so
I really had to do it without like
having someone to bounce off of but she
was super generous and she just kept
letting me
I kept changing what stories that was
gonna use from these two collections cuz
it was just hard figuring out which ones
work together and I wasn't sure I had
tried some other some other things first
on my own that didn't work and some
things with I had this whole long thing
with the writer that move Wow too bad my
brain but anyway it'll come to me in a
minute George tolls I tried to work with
a different writer in Canada and that
didn't really work out it was so I was
finding my it was good for me to have to
like search around and figure it out
like I felt good that I was figuring it
out but I wrote my friend who's a writer
here in town Patrick DeWitt right before
I started shooting and I said I'm still
not sure a triptych is a good idea and
he wrote me back yeah it's probably not
triptychs he's usually not a good we
just wrote a triptych with the famous
now with a famous we just finished the
script which three three different
stories so we'll see how yeah I wrote
I'm Adan's writer and I in Canada and I
had this idea of like wanting I always
have this idea of wanting to break away
from the way I make films like they're
so strict and and I admire his
filmmaking and his like ability to just
use montage and just the way he tells
not
linear stories and so but it's
impossible I had just totally don't have
that brain so but I I tried that for
like gave that like six or seven months
of just yeah and is it the same when
you're filming and when you when you're
shooting do you enjoy it or is it a bit
of a I enjoyed I mean I enjoy planning
how I'm gonna shoot something a lot um
sometimes I enjoyed shooting first cow a
lot I really did it was like my best
experience you know sometimes it's just
I mean I enjoy parts of it definitely
but wish we have stretched ourselves
sometimes like too thin for what we have
and and I just like it certain women I
just was like oh wow it's just I'm too
old to be this cold this many hours and
still be able to think but the coldness
was like and the whole idea of the
payoff of the coldness was certain women
was meant to be this completely white
film and it was so snowy the whole time
we prepped and we prepped through all
the snow and then the stove and it
didn't snow anymore and it's brown beige
film so but it was it was like too cold
too soon oh I'm whole things in form to
film in the process and you know there's
there's something that you know stays
yeah or you know changes everything for
the better and then you end up thinking
you know there was no other way to make
this film and this is how it should have
been yeah but sometimes I mean whatever
yeah there's things in certain women
that I really I look like all the
Montana trucks pile
would snow all the dirty snow I really
missed that cuz it was just like I had
all these parking lots because the
parking lots looks so amazing with the
mountains of dirty snow everywhere and
then I just ended up with the ugly
modern cars in parking lots like so but
yeah but I really enjoyed shooting
I think cuz working with the same Chris
Carroll the same assistant director and
Chris blah Belt all this time has really
put us like would get really in sync and
I really enjoy working with those guys
and I like ya now seemed like extremely
economical and you know how you you know
show everything and was it
did you shoot much more than what you
used or no I mean like maybe more takes
but I sort of fell on the sword a lot
for how segments would be put together
without a lot of options just you know
so I had figured it out beforehand like
you couldn't really cut like some scenes
you could cut into but other scenes were
really built to uh but we had a little
bit more time to sort of map that out
and it was the first time it got to
build like you know we were building the
little hutches and stuff so I really got
to work with Tony Despero the production
designer and design when I was doing the
shots as how so with crease do you go
through the script and kind of design
short specific short and how it scene is
gonna be shot that I first when I'm
writing the script I'm kind of coming up
with ideas of how I wanna when I'm
working on the my passes of the and then
I usually like build some books like I
just have some books I'm sending him all
the time of images and stuff and then I
just sort of start to build a book that
goes
through the movie before he comes and
then we ne then we start from there
and there's holes in that but it has the
sort of shooting strategy like the
language that we're going to use and so
we go through it shot by shot and he
takes notes like we build a shooting
list to go with these images and then
we're as we get the actual locations and
stuff were photographing sometimes it's
him and Chris Carroll the assistant
director of them someone going through
like we shoot out the blocking like I
then that kind of starts to replace the
pictures and the it becomes more and
more and then when we get there by the
time like Chris Hoy's gets so frustrated
because there's so much building I'm so
like the books the books the books and
the list the list but then when we get
there and he's always like well on the
list and I'm like I don't want to see
that I'm like I know it by then and the
actors are there and I don't want to
think about those things anymore it's
sort of like I've learned what I want to
learn want to learn through the process
of building it and uh and then I just
wanna sort of we we watch the actors go
through it - and then we're I mean like
it's funny Mike one of my staff Tyrolean
oak ris comes back like okay now what do
we do just like the but we're in sync
enough like it really helps to not be
starting from scratch with someone it's
so nice to just be having this endless
conversation with it's such a nice
collaboration I I really like it yeah
that's the making for me finding the
right DP yeah no find when you you know
you go
and plan it beforehand you kind of
create a language like a common language
and then you can you know you can always
change it you can shift things around
but there's you know you've you've
agreed on a certain kind of language I
mean in fine now to say and then you
don't need to look at the short list or
you know all your notes and these things
unless maybe when you're stuck and you
go like I can't you know I can't figure
out what we need to do on this like
let's see what we had thought of you
know before but I yeah I find it useful
to do it and then throw it away and then
go bring it back when you're in trouble
it's pretty funny because it's all just
like people walking to the camera and a
pan just pans
yes no I was really you know envious
watching your film saying you know how
you know with yeah like how economical
it can be and but at the same time
include everything and ya know it's it's
you presented as something really simple
but it's not and then figuring out where
to put all the pixels so they'll and
it's exactly right so in the end they
don't obscure the view of the important
things what about um the other you work
with different cinematographers yeah I
mean recently I I worked with Robbie
Ryan I mean I used to work for many
years with someone that I I went to film
school with and
you know I did a thousands of
commercials and other things with and I
used to work with him mostly and then
another DP I did one film with another
DP that I also knew a lot from smaller
projects so that they were people that I
knew quite well in or is it the same /
do you work with you have a producing
partner that you're doing last few films
yeah we're working with that guy me and
Andrew Lowe they have element pictures
so they we've been yeah the last few
films we've made together and all the
films that I've been developing now and
developing with them which is quite
important I think to find that you know
they're behind you you know no matter
what you know the next thing you want to
do is they're like yep
let's just yeah see how that one yank so
it is very helpful it's it's it's a
thing it's you know you reach a point
like it's good to have to find the
people that you're comfortable working
with and you have a shorthand and you
know you get to know them really well
and then sometimes and I don't know when
that moment comes in for what department
or what element of filmmaking but you
also need to make a change and feel like
you're you're entering and you know a
new kind of space or era or whatever you
want to call it so I think it's always a
balance between these things and it's
hard it's hard to find people and like
as you say you know to find that DP that
you can work with and now that I work
with Robbie I really want to work with
him again
you know I work with sound with Johnny
Byrne I started working with him from
the lobster and then we did the killing
of a sacred deer and the favorite and
you know now he's like someone where I
that I send the script when we have a
you know first draft of the script I
sent him the script and the same with
Robby and you know like it's this is
what I'm thinking and they you know this
they they come in early on in the
process we it's quite useful
you can walk on it set with any opinion
they're gonna put the camera right where
you want you're not gonna have to like
you're not gonna have to jump through
any tonight it doesn't all work this
well now I'm old so you know people
listen to me but you know it's a if you
rein the camera the rain around the
camera can be quite macho or but ya know
with Chris yeah so did you find in the
beginning ya know it's gonna stop what
was the first film that you shot with
Chris he came in - Meeks cut off it
didn't work out with the person I
started the movie with and what we
reshot a lot of stuff and um yeah I met
him at like 5:00 in the morning on the
way to uh on the way to the shoot and I
like we got there and I was like you
know the camera goes here and it was the
first time that ever just camera he was
just so cool and he just put the camera
there and then he was like you wanted to
move and I was like I love this guy
like I couldn't believe it I didn't have
to negotiate I'd have to say why it's
better than it goes here then somewhere
else
I didn't it was just so I was like oh my
god uh you know I mean I had shot with a
friend of mine old joy you know it's
really just whose documentary filmmaker
so it's just a different kind of
shooting because like the
always being held so I could really
never get behind the camera but I like
that guy I like his pizza and I liked
his work a lot but it's uh and then the
UM Sam Levy we worked on Wendy and Lucy
together Sam levees like your size and
the cameras always up here and I'm like
I just don't see the world that way I'm
just like what do you do it like there's
so many things you know Sam's not a
macho person either it's just that it's
really hard to all of it you know it
does matter how you see the world and so
but I don't know somehow with Chris it
was it was just so for whatever reason
we just got into a groove so fast and by
that point all my friends nobody would
recommend a DP to me because everyone
was like ever wants to recommend anybody
to me but it was yeah I was like my
first day with him was like Mike just
one of the best days of shooting ever
and I was like reinvigorated and I yeah
it was uh it was great he said to me
well what do you think what do you think
you're missing that you don't have and I
was this was just like we were way
behind and we had to reshoot stuff it
was just like this was just a talk in
the van of fantasy stuff I said well you
know if I had my way like all things I
you know we'd got to this other location
we'd set the tracks and I explained this
shot to him and the next day we're
shooting and then it we break for lunch
and they tell me to get in the van and
we go out and he's got the tracks and
it's all set up and I was I couldn't
believe it I was like wow like yeah so
everything to find he yeah I mean he's
like you know he's like a third
generation camera guy yeah so he's been
on sets his whole life and he's yeah
he's - just like what do you want
what a great attitude so yeah but do you
do you find yourself thank you you find
you can keep your the crews small enough
so that you're flexible and because it's
not something that I've been struggling
with especially starting from Greece
which was basically you know like five
people in total you know no money just
friends making films yeah and then you
know making the jump to making
english-language films and entering a
much more structured environment in an
industry and people that do it in a
certain way I I struggled you know to
find the way of making things with the
flexibility and spontaneity that I I was
able to do things before so I'm always
you know fighting for less people on set
less people that need it overall and but
you you've somehow managed to well
because it all has to do with how little
money we had because it's a union thing
yeah
and in in like this new script we have
we can't quite get the budget to where
we had first cow and it will put us in
the realm of Teamsters like driver for
every vehicle which would change the
entire vibe of how I've been able to
make film so far because it has been you
know as much as like we push ourselves
too far for what we have the the crew is
really intimate and it does I feel like
it it shows up in the film somehow you
know like maybe the stretch
shows up in the films too but like I
don't know on a bigger crew maybe
happens to like you know at the end of
the day when you're just you're losing
light and everyone hits their stride and
if you've been
working with people a lot of times
before just the way everyone's like all
of a sudden at their best just like
getting that last shot before you lose
the Sun or whatever that which is like
my favorite thing but and I once caught
a fish Jurgis while that was happening
we're shooting right on the river
waiting for the car to go around to
shoot it up above and the - chris has
always have their fishing lines and I
can't iconic fish just what's up did you
eat it afterwards with them it would
have been quite a little appetizer but
but I do but I don't know does that kind
of synchronicity happen on with a lot
with on a bigger film well I haven't
done like really big films but I think
favorite your biggest film yeah
something like that
I couldn't tell you an exact number but
it just felt like it's it's still a film
with three main actors in ya know in a
couple of rooms so so you're not even
chasing the light because you're like
inside a lot yeah but we are change
chasing the life as I we showed with
natural light so we don't we don't like
natural light all inside yeah you
created the naturally it's very
beautiful yeah oh wow yeah no it's and
again it's like your DP needs to be
really on board with that and you know
Robbie was really great about that like
he was like no lights I go like no lies
I don't want lights it's one of the
actors that's amazing so yeah you had to
but only that you would have to
because it sounds like you have windows
on both sides right so what are you
doing like you only have a certain
amount of each day you can shoot yeah I
mean when you we have no exposure you
just stop filming
you have no exposure the Sun goes behind
a tree or the other side of that's it
yeah well I'm not the thing is like and
I think it's it's useful to you know
convey that you know to the DP and I I'm
not concerned with you know perfect
light and continuity and those kind of
things so you know basically most of the
times is like if you you know if you
have the exposure we can you know you
can shoot it and it's not good so yeah
we should for as long as we have the
exposure and it doesn't matter if you
know the light is slightly this way or
the other way or it got darker or it's
me or you know somehow it works I find
and I kind of appreciate it as well like
all those little we had I'm just the
online graduation of the seniors it
barred where I teach and the students
were thanking the professors for the
different things like you taught me how
to see the world like this and you
taught me how to all the different and
then with me and you taught me
continuity tired about continue to
sometimes it's me too
[Music]
so that's something I could even afford
to be do you have unions there of course
right it depends where you shoot but in
London you must wear I mean it's not
it's not the same way but it's kind of
organized in
in a similar way I mean it's not like
unions but there is a very specific
structure and rules so it's yeah it's
kind it's kind of the same I guess it's
it's quite useful force you know for
part of it but then sometimes it just
becomes absurd you know the you know the
reasons why you need to do certain
things or spend a certain amount of
money on things that you don't
necessarily need but it's because you
know your film your film reaches you
know that tier for instance or yeah so
you know so you have to have those that
many trucks
or that many people or you know that
many stands for lights although you
don't really need them or you don't use
them so it's it's just always a struggle
to try and find the balance and but yeah
I mean I because you asked before like
if you can if you can maintain you know
like a certain kind of enthusiasm about
you know the short and they and the
moment and all those kind of things I
think it's it's just important to find
the right people no matter what the
system is the size and and you know if
the heads of department and are the
right people then they choose the right
people to work then they choose you know
the next set of people and that's you
know that's the only way that you can
achieve something like that I mean I was
my my first shoot my first dinner on my
first english-language film I was sure
shocked like the first day that the that
they showed me the there was like you
have two minutes still to conclude the
shot I was like what like you mean it's
like and then it's done I could like
what you know like where's here and
we've done you know saying I might need
like another minute and a half maybe is
that approximately
we have to agree to it and if you had to
talk about it for two minutes yeah and
I'm talking about it as well but I was
so shocked that I nobody has ever told
me that before like you have you know
like two minutes to you know either
complete the shot or so it's from you
know from then on I try to you know
enter a different kind of mind state to
get things done but it's it's it's it's
difficult to different problems we're
making films in Greece you know like and
you didn't have any money then you had
different problems I mean you came you
know you couldn't choose anything you
couldn't make choices on you know what
color t-shirt someone would wear because
it had to be one of our friends that
longer have a yellow one they had a blue
one so you have to you know have a
t-shirt for your character that kind of
problem you go to you know like you have
two minutes so you make your next film
wherever in whatever cut you have
options like whatever country opens
first you take that you do that project
yeah I guess yeah I mean since I'm not
making films in Greece anymore it's like
you know and I'm like you settled on
that no no really I'm just saying like
you know because of life I guess and
because even when I moved to London I
ended up making a film in Ireland and a
film in the US and then I showed a film
in in England after
it was the third film that I ended up
shooting where I moved so you never
really know you know where where the
next project is gonna take you me it
could be like downtown Portland or
Eastern Oregon or where did you shoot
first in Oregon or I I don't know how I
ended up being an Oregon filmmaker it's
completely puzzling in like an hour
outside of Portland you know what's it
what's the next one where is that gonna
be so have you written it yeah it's like
a block for me I wouldn't even need a
driver I would just well if this school
we want to shoot at you know it might
just end up being like this is them this
is what we're looking for kind of thing
it's like it would be hard to replace
it's this arts and crafts school here in
Portland but it they're gonna fix it up
and all the funkiness
I think might get lost it's not actually
in a great place for sound it's pretty
noisy where it is it's too bad when
we're shooting first cow man the
airplane traffic was just killing me I
mean you couldn't every 30 seconds
there's another plane it really changed
between like Meeks cut off and first cow
like the amount of planes like right now
there's no plane traffic so I and
there's no shooting driving me crazy but
um yeah no it's not I mean we just tend
to well John writes for this area and
now I've somehow fallen into the trap of
it too but I mean the thing with first
counts that first time I ever filmed and
I went home at night and not to uh now
just always working on a hotel room bed
like that's your desk that's where you
sleep that's where you know is coming
home at night man
or oh it's great I loved it I well also
it's like first time at home so I was
like like that anyway but I mean it's
true you know your daily you know but
you're just ignoring your mail and all
that shit anyway but just to have all
your books in your own bed and I found
it I think I try and find the positive
of filming elsewhere by assuming that
we're kind of entering this dimension
and you were there at the time and there
are no other you know destruction from
your real life and you're in this place
and you're making this film and there's
nothing else so I guess there's a was
into that and then it got broken and I
was like this is actually I mean just on
a yeah just to be able to come home and
cook a potato before bed I don't know it
wasn't
I loved that we're all away in a also
but I don't know everything about first
cow is better because we shot five-day
weeks for the first time and it was
rainy in 30 degrees whatever you could
dress for that so the light was always
good but it wasn't freezing it was like
it was uh and the biggest difference was
my producers and I agreed we would never
be in a car together and that was like
fantastic Bank
I was just great like I didn't hear all
the production problems I didn't know
every single problem that was going on
it's very good it was very good I always
used to drive to set with them and it
was just like I couldn't even think of
what I was gonna do that day cuz I'd be
like hearing about it it was like the
bet it was a small change but it was
huge I could just be in my little dream
space before I went to work and uh that
was cool I don't know
yeah we'll see what the future brings
how long was it first car the the shoot
it was 30 shooting days but it was
five-day weeks and Thanksgiving was in
the middle of it we had like four days
down in the middle of the shoot which
was I was spill my every right could
yeah I could really think while we were
making the film usually you just leave
and you feel like oh we got so close but
we didn't get what we wanted but there's
no time to mourn it because tomorrow is
another day
I mean it had some of that but it was
like you had the weekend to like the the
canoe scene for example yeah those shots
with the canoes and that the first time
we shot that that was a disaster I it
was my way of trying to shoot it inside
the canoe is awful like the picture boat
was in our shot every river was really
fast moving even though it looked calm
on top and those boats are like they're
it's a tree basically dug out so I had
to reconsider and thank God I had the
weekend to figure it out so you
reassured that yeah we reshot that that
was our beauty shoot day and great that
you know all these things that will you
win wrong on the film said and then you
know you hide all these things from the
film and we watch it and think it's
absolutely perfect and everything worked
amazingly and then it's basically
managing to you know cut out hide
everything that went wrong and present
this thing is pristine yeah Chris you
know you know all of the stuff that went
down and can you ever can you ever get
enough distance to watch the film and
forget about all that and kind of
through it I don't watch it I don't want
to especially the editing I think I
would or the sound design I would be
like I was in such a rabbit hole with
those crickets and birds every bird I
was just like I redid a remix just for
the crickets and birds to make sure that
all the birds were like Northwestern and
placed them all and one's gonna watch it
on their flat screens they're gonna hear
my crickets or my Birds I was positive
that like people were gonna get tripped
up by the rhythm of the crickets I mean
I was in such a you could go so far in a
hole with things but the rhythm of the
crickets didn't probably even occur to
you right it doesn't you know you don't
have to you know consciously realize all
these things when you're watching
something you know you know them and you
you know but you know people that watch
it I mean I think all these things work
and of course it's on a different scale
depending on how they watch it in in
what kind of conditions but they all
contribute into the and they were
enhanced in some strange way look we
passed the
you